[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chapter five
coraline locked the door of the drawing
room with a cold black key
she went back into the kitchen and
climbed onto a chair
she tried to put the bunch of keys back
on top of the door frame again
she tried four or five times before she
was forced to accept that she just
wasn't big enough
and she put them down on the counter
next to the door
her mother still hadn't returned from
her shopping expedition
coraline went to the freezer and took
out the spare loaf of frozen bread in
the bottom compartment
she made herself some toast with jam and
peanut butter she drank a glass of water
she waited for her parents to come back
when it began to get dark coraline
microwaved herself a frozen pizza
then coraline watched television she
wondered why grown-ups gave themselves
all the good programs with all the
shouting and running around in
after a while she started yawning then
she undressed brushed her teeth and put
herself to bed
in the morning she went into her parents
room but their bed hadn't been slept in
and they weren't around
she ate canned spaghetti for breakfast
for lunch she had a block of cooking
chocolate and an apple
the apple was yellow and slightly
shriveled but it tasted sweet and good
for tea she went down to see mrs [ __ ]
enforceable she had three digestive
biscuits a glass of limeade and a cup of
wheat tea
the limeade was very interesting it
didn't taste anything like limes
it tasted bright green and vaguely
chemical carline liked it enormously
she wished they had it at home how are
your dear mother and father
asked mrs pink missing said coraline
i haven't seen either of them since
yesterday i'm on my own
i think i've probably become a single
child family
tell your mother that we found the
glasgow empire press clintons we were
telling her about
she seemed very interested when miriam
mentioned them to her
she's vanished under mysterious
circumstances said coraline
and i believe my father has as well i'm
afraid we'll be out all day tomorrow
caroline levy
said miss forcible we'll be staying over
with april's niece and royal tunbridge
wells
they showed coraline a photographic
album with photographs of miss spink's
niece in it and then carline went home
she opened her money box and walked down
to the supermarket
she bought two large bottles of limeade
a chocolate cake and a new bag of apples
and went back home and ate them for
dinner she cleaned her teeth and went
into her father's office
she woke up his computer and wrote a
story
coraline's story there was a girl her
name was apple
she used to dance a lot she danced and
danced until her free turned into
sausages the end she printed out the
story and turned off the computer
then she drew a picture of the little
girl dancing underneath the words on the
paper
she ran herself a bath with too much
bubble bath in it and the bubbles ran
over the side and went all over the
floor
she dried herself and the floor as best
she could
and went to bed
carline woke up in the night she went
into her parents bedroom
but the bed was made and empty the
glowing green numbers on the digital
clock glowed at 3 12 am
all alone in the middle of the night
carline began to cry
there was no other sound in the empty
flat
she climbed into her parents bed and
after a while
she went to sleep portland was woken by
cold paws batting her face
she opened her eyes big green eyes
stared back at her
it was the cat hello said coraline
how did you get in the cat didn't say
anything
coraline got out of bed she was wearing
a long t-shirt and pajama bottoms
have you come to tell me something the
cat yawned
which made its eyes flash green do you
know where mommy and daddy are
the cat blinked at her slowly is that a
yes
the cat blinked again coraline decided
that that was indeed a yes
will you take me to them the cat stared
at her
then it walked out into the hall she
followed it it walked the length of the
corridor and stopped down at the very
end where a full-length mirror hung
the mirror had been a long time before
the inside of a wardrobe door
it had been hanging there on the wall
when they moved in and although
coraline's mother had spoken
occasionally of replacing it with
something newer she never had
coraline turned on the light in the home
the mirror showed the corridor behind
her
that was only to be expected but
reflected in the mirror were her parents
they stood awkwardly in the reflection
of the hall they seemed sad and alone
as coraline watched they waved to her
slowly
with limp hands carline's father had his
arm around her mother
in the mirror coraline's mother and
father stared at her her father opened
his mouth and said something but she
could hear nothing at all
her mother breathed on the inside of the
mirror glass and quickly
before the fog faded she wrote help us
with the tip of her forefinger the fog
on the inside of the mirror faded and so
did her parents
and now the mirror reflected only the
corridor and coraline
and the cat where are they
coraline asked the cat the cat made no
reply but coraline could imagine
its voice dry as a dead fly on a
windowsill in winter saying
well where do you think they are
they aren't going to come back are they
say coraline
not under their own steam the cat
blinked at her
coraline took it as a yes right said
coraline
and i suppose there's only one thing
left to do
she walked into her father's study she
sat down at his desk
then she picked up the telephone and she
opened the phone book and telephoned the
local police station
police said a gruff male voice
hello she said my name is coraline jones
you're up a bit after your bedtime
aren't you young lady
said the policeman possibly say coraline
who is not going to be diverted but i am
ringing to report a crime
and what sort of crime would that be
kidnapping
grown-up napping really my parents have
been stolen away into a world on the
other side of the mirror in our hall
and do you know who stole them asked the
police officer
carline could hear the smile in his
voice and she tried extra hard to sound
like an adult might sound
to make him take her seriously i think
my other mother has them both in her
clutches
she may want to keep them and sew their
eyes with black buttons
or she may simply have them in order to
lure me back into the reach of her
fingers
i'm not sure ah
the nefarious clutches of her fiendish
fingers is it
he said you know what i suggest miss
jones
no say coraline what you ask your mother
to make you a big old mug of hot
chocolate
and then give you a great big old hug
there's nothing like hot chocolate and a
hug for making the nightmares go away
and if she starts to tell you off for
waking her up at this time of night
while you tell her that that's what the
policeman said he had a deep
reassuring voice coraline was not
reassured
when i see her say coraline i shall tell
her that
and she put down the telephone the black
cat
who had sat on the floor grooming his
fur through this entire conversation
now stood up and led the way into the
hall
coraline went back into her bedroom and
put on her blue dressing gown in her
slippers
she looked under the sink for a
flashlight and found one but the
batteries had long since run down and it
barely glowed with a faintest straw
colored light
she put it down again and found a box of
in case of emergency
white wax candles and thrust one into a
candlestick
she put an apple into each pocket she
picked up the ring of keys and took the
old black key off the ring
she walked into the drawing room and
looked at the door
she had the feeling that the door was
looking at her
which she knew was silly and knew on a
deeper level was somehow true
she went back into her bedroom and
rummaged in the pocket of her jeans
she found the stone with the hole in it
and put it into her dressing gown pocket
she lit the candle wick with a match and
watched sputter and light
then she picked up the black key it was
cold in her hand
she put it into the keyhole in the door
but did not turn the key
i was a little girl said coraline to the
cat
when we lived in our old house a long
long time ago my dad took me for a walk
on the wasteland between our house and
the shops
it wasn't the best place to go for a
walk really there were all these things
that people had thrown away back there
old cookers and broken dishes and dolls
with no arms and no legs
and empty cans and broken bottles mom
and dad made me promise not to go
exploring back there
because there were too many sharp things
and tetanus and such
but i kept telling him i wanted to
explore it so one day my dad put on his
big brown boots and his gloves and put
my boots on me and my
jeans and sweater and we went for a walk
we must have walked for about 20 minutes
he went down this hill to the bottom of
a gully where a stream was
when my dad suddenly turned to me
coraline run away
up the hill now he said it in a tight
sort of way
urgently so i did i ran away up the hill
something hurt me on the back of my arm
as i ran but i kept running
as i got to the top of the hill i heard
somebody thundering up the hill behind
me
it was my dad charging like a rhino when
he reached me he picked me up in his
arms and swept me over the edge of the
hill
and then we stopped and we puffed and we
panted and we looked back
down the goalie the air was alive with
yellow wasps
we must have stepped on a wasp's nest
and a rotten branch as we walked
and while i was running up the hill my
dad stayed and got stung
to give me time to run away his glasses
had fallen off when he ran
i only had the one sting on the back of
my arm he had 39 stings all over him
we counted later in the bath
the black cat began to wash its face and
whiskers in a manner that indicated
increasing impatience
coraline reached down and stroked the
back of its head and neck
the cat stood up walked several paces
until it was out of her reach
then it sat down and looked up at her
again so
said coraline later that afternoon my
dad went back again to the wasteland to
get his glasses back
he said if he had left it another day
wouldn't be able to remember where
they'd fallen
and soon he got home wearing his glasses
he said that he wasn't scared when he
was standing there
and the wasps were stinging him and
hurting him and he was watching me run
away
because he knew he had to give me enough
time to run or the wasp would have come
after both of us
carline turned the key in the door it
turned with a loud clunk
the door swung open there was no brick
wall on the other side of the door
only darkness a cold wind blew through
the passageway
coraline made no move to walk through
the door and he said that wasn't brave
of him
doing that just standing there and being
stung said coraline to the cat
it wasn't brave because he wasn't scared
it was the only thing he could do
but going back again to get his glasses
when he knew the wasps were there
when he was really scared that was brave
she took her first step down the dark
corridor she could smell dust and damp
and mustiness
the cat patted along beside her and why
was that
asked the cat although it sounded barely
interested
because she said when you're scared but
you still do it anyway
that's brave the candle casts
huge strange flickering shadows along
the wall
she heard something moving in the
darkness beside her
or to one side of her but she could not
tell
it seemed if it was keeping pace with
her whatever it was
and that's why you're going back to her
world then
said the cat because your father once
saved you from wasps
don't be silly say coraline i'm going
back for them because they were my
parents
and if they noticed i was gone i'm sure
they would do the same for me you know
you're talking again
how fortunate i am said the cat and
having a traveling companion of such
wisdom and intelligence
his tone remained sarcastic but its fur
was bristling
and its brush of a tail stuck up in the
air coraline was going to say something
like
sorry or wasn't it a lot shorter walk
last time when the candle went out as
suddenly as it had been snuffed by
someone's hand
there was a scrabbling and a pattern and
coraline could feel her heart pounding
against her ribs
she put out one hand and felt something
wispy
like a spider's web brush her hands in
her face
[Music]
at the end of the corridor the electric
light was on blinding after the darkness
a woman stood silhouetted by the light a
little ahead of coraline
coraline darling she called mama
said coraline and she ran forward eager
and relieved
darling said the woman why did you ever
run away from me
carline was too close to stop and she
felt the other mother's cold arms and
fooled her
she stood there rigid and trembling as
the other mother held her tightly
where are my parents coraline asked
we're here said the other mother and a
voice so close to her
real mothers that coraline could
scarcely tell them apart we're here
we're ready to love you and play with
you and feed you and make your life
interesting coraline pulled back
and the other mother let her go with
reluctance the other father who had been
sitting on a chair in the hallway stood
up and smiled
come into the kitchen he said i'll make
us a midnight snack
and you want something to drink hot
chocolate perhaps
coraline walked down the hallway until
she reached the mirror at the end
there was nothing reflected in it but a
young girl in her dressing gown and
slippers
who looked like she had recently been
crying but whose eyes were realized
not black buttons and who was holding
tightly to a burned out candle in a
candlestick
she looked at the girl in the mirror and
the girl in the mirror looked back at
her
i will be brave thought coraline
no i am brave she put down the
candlestick on the floor
then turned around the other mother and
the other father were looking at her
hungrily
i don't need a snack she said i have an
apple
see and she took an apple from her
dressing gown pocket
then bit into it with relish and an
enthusiasm that she did not really feel
the other father looked disappointed the
other mother smiled
showing a full set of teeth and each of
the teeth was
a tiny bit too long the lights in the
hallway made her black button eyes
glitter and gleam
you don't frighten me said coraline
although they did frighten her
very much i want my parents back
the world seemed to shimmer a little at
the edges
whatever what i've done with your old
parents if they have left you coraline
it must
be because they became bored of you or
tired
now i will never become bored of you and
i will never abandon you
you will always be safe here with me the
other mother's wet looking black hair
drifted around her head like the
tentacles of a creature
in the deep ocean they weren't bored of
me
said coraline you're lying you stole
them
silly silly coraline they are fine
wherever they are
coraline simply glared at the other
mother i'll prove it
said the other mother and brush the
surface of the mirror with her long
white fingers
it clouded over as if a dragon had
breathed on it and then it cleared
in the mirror it was daytime already
carline was looking at the hallway
all the way down to her front door the
door opened from the outside and
carlin's mother and father walked inside
they carried suitcases that was a fine
holiday
said coraline's father how nice it is
not to have coraline anymore said her
mother with a happy smile
now we can do all the things we always
wanted to do like go abroad
but were prevented from doing by having
a little daughter
and said her father i take great comfort
in knowing that her other mother will
take better
care of her than we ever could the
mirror fogged and faded
and reflected the night once more see
said her other mother no
say coraline i don't see and i don't
believe it either
she hoped that what she had just seen
was not real but she was not as certain
as she sounded
there was a tiny doubt inside her like a
maggot and an apple core
then she looked up and saw the
expression on her other mother's face
a flash of real anger which crossed her
face like summer lightning
and coraline was sure in her heart that
what she had seen in the mirror was no
more than an illusion
carline sat down on the sofa and ate her
apple
please said her other mother don't be
difficult
she walked into the drawing room and
clapped her hands twice
there was a wrestling noise and a black
rat appeared it stared up at her
bring me the key she said
the rat chittered then it ran through
the open door that led back to
coraline's own flat
the rat returned dragging the key behind
it
why don't you have your own key on this
side as coraline
there's only one key only one door said
the other father
hush said the other mother he must not
bother our darling coralines headed with
such trivialities
she put the key in the keyhole and
twisted the lock was stiff
but it clumped closed she dropped the
key into her apron pocket
outside the sky had begun to lighten to
a luminous gray
if we aren't going to have a midnight
snack said the other mother we still
need our beauty sleep
i am going back to bed coraline i would
strongly suggest that you do the same
she placed her long white fingers on the
shoulders of the other father
and she walked him out of the room
coraline walked over to the door at the
far corner of the drawing room
she tugged on it but it was tightly
locked the door of her other parents
bedroom was now closed
she was indeed tired but she did not
want to sleep in the bedroom
she did not want to sleep under the same
roof as her other mother
the front door was not locked coraline
walked out into the dawn
and down the stone stairs she sat down
on the bottom step
it was cold something furry pushed
itself against her side in one smooth
insinuating motion
coraline jumped then breathed a sigh of
relief when she saw what it was
oh it's you she said to the black cat
see said the cat it wasn't so hard
recognizing me was it
even without names well what if i wanted
to call you
the cat wrinkled its nose and managed to
look unimpressed
calling cats it confided tends to be a
rather overrated activity
might as well call a whirlwind what if
it was dinner time
as coraline wouldn't you want to be
called then of course
said the cat but a simple cry of dinner
would do nicely see no need for names
why does she want me coraline asked the
cat
why does she want me to stay here with
her
she wants something to love i think said
the cat
something that isn't her she might want
something to eat as well it's hard to
tell with creatures like that
do you have any advice asked coraline
the cat looked as if they were about to
say something else sarcastic
then it flicked its whiskers and said
challenge her
there's no guarantee she'll play fair
but her kind of thing loves games and
challenges
what kind of thing is that as coraline
but the cat made no answer simply
stretched looked juriently and walked
away
then it stopped and turned and said i'd
go inside if i were you
get some sleep you have a long day ahead
of you
and then the cat was gone still coraline
realized it had a point
she cried back into the silent house
past the closed bedroom door inside
which the other mother
and the other father what she wondered
slept waited
and then it came to her that should she
open the bedroom door
she would find it empty or more
precisely
that it was an empty room and would
remain empty until the exact moment that
she opened the door
somehow that made it easier coraline
walked into the green and pink parody of
her own bedroom
she closed the door and hauled the toy
box in front of it it would not
keep anyone out but the noise somebody
would make trying to dislodge it
would wake her she hoped the toys in the
toy box were still mostly asleep
and they stirred and muttered as she
moved their box and then they went back
to sleep
coraline checked under her bed looking
for rants but there was nothing there
she took off her dressing gown and
slippers and climbed into bed
and fell asleep with barely enough time
to reflect as she did so
on what the cat could have meant by a
challenge
[Applause]
[Music]
you